none of us ever know when we're going to
get sick and I'm a nurse I've never had
a cigarette I don't drink a sip of
alcohol I got this disease what you
learn is that you can't have people
around you who are negative or what I
have learned to call the assassins of
joy people that take your daily joy away
is really key and so important to have
people with positive energy in your life
and to surround yourself with as many
positive people as you can there are so
many enchanting moments in life and a
lot of them have to deal with
interactions between you and strangers
the bagger at the Whole Foods step
substances let me bag all your stuff go
to the car with you and put it in the
car for you when you know you have a
terminal disease it makes you enjoy
everything so many of us are so busy all
day doing things we miss enchanting
moments we rarely capture them and we
rarely enjoy them you need to be
grateful and thankful for those moments
and remember them and let them help
propel you through the day with joy I
think you need to choose well who you
surround yourself with who you spend
your time with what activities you
engage and be very easy when you're not
feeling well to lay in bed for 10 hours
and not do anything but watch TV I
choose to paint I choose to do my art
play the piano when I go for five or six
hours of chemo I don't go in my pajamas
and sit in the chair like a victim I
bring my watercolors with me my quilting
with me I bring some activity I'm
extremely busy the whole entire time
that I'm getting my chemotherapy what
you need to do is to enjoy every moment
you need to surround yourself with good
people you need to live your life with
enjoyment and
soozee Azzam you need to look around and
help people around you help people in
your life I want to be remembered as
somebody who was enchanted by moments
all throughout the day and someone who
tried it cause enchanting moments for
others I want to be remembered as
somebody that brought joy into people's
lives and who had integrity and was a
good person I want to be remembered as
somebody who passionately loves her
husband and her children and her
grandchildren and never acted as the
victim but always has acted as the
warrior and was unafraid of anything
you